another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do with the foundation challenge  accepted is not a valid excuse for  anything just because someone speaks  hyperbolically around you or uses a  figure of speech that does not mean you  should say challenge accepted and take  it as an invitation to act on whatever  was said this includes but is not  limited to i'm so hungry i could eat a  horse i'm drowning in paperwork these  new shoes are killing me and that's so  cute i could just die accepting a  hypothetical challenge is also not an  excuse to flood the canteen with hot  coffee attempt to reverse the polarity  of gravity or attempt to get scp-682 to  smile it is not a get out of jail free  card dr bright you will go to jail